[Musik]
wann haben sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer zum letzten mal gespielt und
sind sie dazu zu einem priester in den
beichtstuhl gegangen oder fühlen sie
sich mit ihren schuldgefühlen auf der
couch des psychiaters besser aufgehoben
warum genügt es nicht gott oder dem
eigenen gewissen gegenüber direkt
rechenschaft abzulegen
mit meinen beiden gästen spreche ich
heute über schuld vergebung untreue
herzlich willkommen ob gewann federer
vorsteher des klosters einsiedeln und
daniel strassberg psychoanalytiker und
philosoph turban in vorbereitung auf
dieses gespräch habe ich mit zahlreichen
katholikinnen und katholiken gesprochen
männern und frauen alten und jungen nur
sehr wenige haben mir positive
erlebnisse erzählt wie war das bei ihnen
als ich zum ersten mal zur beichte
gegangen sind
das allererste mal so genau kann ich
mich dann nicht mehr erinnern aber die
ersten male was ich war sicher sehr
nervös denn es ging um etwas anderes es
ging um dinge wie gehe ich mit meinen
eltern mit meinen geschwistern also das
erzähle ich ja normalerweise nicht so
auf der straße
ich war sehr nervös und auf der anderen
seite darf ich sagen es war etwas für
mich positives was ich habe hier nie
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht sondern
durfte einfach da wieder raus gehen und
das war's lange straßberg sie stammen
aus einer jüdischen familie sind in
zürich aufgewachsen haben die
öffentlichen schulen besucht und kamen
sich auch mit katholischen kindern in
kontakt waren sie neidisch als sie
merkten dass die zur beichte gehen
durften oder dachten sie gott sei dank
brauche ich nicht zu gehen weder noch
mein bester freund
in der primarschule war katholik und der
musste jede woche
ich glaube es war mittwochnachmittag
unfall nachmittag in die kirche beichten
gehen und ich ging in meistens begleiten
und das merkwürdige daran ist dass ich
das gefühl hatte eine sünde zu begehen
dass ich überhaupt eine kirche betrete
war obwohl ich glaube meine eltern nie
gesagt haben ich dürfe keine kirche
betrete aber ich hatte das gefühl dass
ihnen der einer übertretung umfang das
ungeheuer spannend dass während wien die
sünden vergeben wurden wie ich eine
beginn das ist interessant und sprechen
gleich noch darüber wie das judentum
auch vielleicht mit der frage der
sündenvergebung umgehen wird zunächst
einmal möchte ich aber gerne wissen
viele katholikinnen und katholiken die
ich befragt haben nach ihrer ersten
beichte die sagten mir praktisch unisono
sie hätten eigentlich gar nicht gewusst
was sie hätten berichten sollen dass sie
hatten gar kein verständnis gar kein
schuldbewusstsein in diesem alter und
viele haben ja auch gesagt sie hätten
daraufhin dinge sogar erfunden also sie
haben eine lüge begangen um dann in die
beichte zu gehen können dann eine
sündenvergebung zu erlangen
was für eine schöne begriff kann ein 78
9 jähriges kind haben
wenn ich am kinder bräuchten denke das
gibt es bei uns in der innerschweiz so
im verein vorbereitung auf die
erstkommunion heute noch das wird heute
ja genau da bin ich eigentlich erstaunt
wie groß die sensibilität von kindern
ist für was gut und nicht gut gut und
böse ist
ich staune eigentlich dass kinder das
bereich zu können weil ich bin auch
immer davon ausgegangen was die mir dann
sagen ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht das
was ich sagen würde würde ich aber heute
nicht mehr so sagen
aber kinder die eine sünde in der
beichte bekennen ich denke jetzt mal
dass sie vielleicht gegenüber den eltern
ungehorsam waren dass sie nicht
ordentlich waren dass sie vielleicht in
der schule vermittelt haben irgend einer
weise dass ich nicht nett verhalten
haben ist das was die katholische kirche
als sünde bezeichnet oder könnte man
nicht sagen das sind tugenden unschöne
ereignisse aber ist das wirklich eine
sünde
also ich denke mir die beichte begleitet
ja auch ein veganes menschen und sowie
das gewissen
von jungen menschen auch gewendet wird
durch sozialverhalten also durch durch
den alltag wird das in der beichte auf
eine religiöse stufe gehoben das auch
von der religion her das gewissen
gebildet wird da muss aber jetzt nicht
jede und jeder einen mord begehen damit
er dann zur beichte kann also ich denke
mir da geht es einfach darum sich immer
wieder die frage zu stellen wie gehe ich
mit meinem leben wie gehe ich mit meiner
freiheit um auch wenn ihr mit diesen
begriffen dann nicht immer so operieren
können sie das als psychoanalytiker
nachvollziehen dass im alter zwischen
sieben und neun eine derartige
auseinandersetzung mit den eigenen
unzulänglichkeiten mit eigenen
fehlerhaftigkeit stattfinden soll
das findet natürlich auf jeden fall
statt also das braucht es die weichen
dazu nicht die kinder lernen wie sie
sich verhalten sollen unternehmen und
die erste art wie man das lernt ist
durch den liebesentzug der älteren denen
man befürchtet wenn man etwas schlechtes
gemacht hat also das erste
sozialverhalten wird durch angst
vermittelt
man hat angst dass eine strafe kommt und
schlimmsten fall der liebesentzug und
daran lernt man was man ob das dann
schon gut und böse ist das weiß ich
nicht aber man lernt wie man sich
verhalten sollen und was mit der band
passiert ist eine ein schritt der ob der
altersadäquat ist oder nicht dass das
kann ich nicht beurteilen aber es kommt
die zeit in dem ich dieses vorab schauen
dass von der eltern internalisieren muss
also ich muss irgendwann lernen mich
nach mir selber zu beurteilen und nicht
nach der reaktion der eltern
mir scheint 7 nach etwas früh zu sein
aber es ist zu einem übergang zu einer
von der reinen externen verhaltens
regulation zu einer internen
verhaltensregeln aktion indem man es
nicht ganz mit sich selber macht sondern
noch jemanden der bei
hat der mich einen darüber spricht also
insofern finde ich das nicht völlig
abwegig nein und brauchten denn oder
brauchen auch heute die kinder in
irgendeiner form vielleicht nicht gerade
liebesentzug aber doch in irgendeiner
weise strafe zu befürchten wenn sie ihre
beichte ablegen in form von gemüse etwa
die das setting einer beichte ist ja ein
religiöses das kann man nicht
vergleichen mit einer couch wie sie das
einleitend gesagt haben
obwohl es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
so stattfindet das heißt da hat ja auch
das wort gott oder das sprechen über
gott platz und wenn ich jetzt mit einem
kind zum beispiel eine geschichte
anschaue
im beispiel von gott dann werde ich
nicht zuerst mit dem wort buße kommen
sondern vielleicht mit den barmherzigen
vater oder mit dem vater der dich liebt
und möchte dass du weiter auf deinem weg
gehst durch die beichte den kindern auch
ein positives gottesbild genau genau und
von sich selbst
was auffällt ist dass früher ein zwang
eine pflicht zur beichte bestanden hat
man ging wöchentlich oder monatlich zur
beichte wird entweder von den eltern
geschickt oder auch die kirche die da
eine gewisse kontrolle ausübt
heute wenn ich auf ihrer homepage von
ihrem kloster in einsiedeln nach sehr
dann wird das als ein angebot formuliert
vom zwang zum angebot wie ist das zu
verstehen
gut ganz vergleichen kann es miteinander
nicht weil wir sind ein wallfahrtsort
wir sind keine pfarrei und was sie
vorher erwähnt haben sind das was früher
frei aus sozialen druck da war das war
ja nicht nur bei der beichte also wenn
der metzger sein fleisch wirklich
verkaufen wollte musste er zur kirche
sonst sind die leute nicht mehr zu ihm
gekommen weil da geht dir nicht in die
kirche und das ist war ja nicht also das
ganze hatte mehr mit druck zu tun
ein wallfahrtsort ist eine möglichkeit
aus dem alltag auszutreten
wir haben wenn es auch viele leute die
gehen über einsiedel nach santiago di
compostela
die machen aus einen weg von bis zu drei
monaten
und wollen dann da irgend ich sage es
bewusst auch einen stein abladen vom
herzen
die nämlich tatsächlich zum teil auch
steine mit also das ist eine besondere
situation wo man sich denkt wenn ich
schon mal in einsiedeln binden könnte
ich doch reichten also nicht ganz
vergleichbar mit leichten die auch
angebot werden in den üblichen anderen
verein ich hoffe inhaltlich schon aber
einfach das kann ein wallfahrtsort das
angebot also da ist war immer so bei
niemand musste in einzigen leichten
gehen werden sonst verliert er soziale
druck in ein dorf auch in einer stadt
schon da war komme den heutigen mehr
leute zu ihnen nach 1 sind unser beichte
als früher wie entwickelt sich das nein
ich denke sind weniger die beiden kinder
verlängert also früher kamen massen an
leuten die nach einzigen kamen heute
sind es zum teil auch gruppen die das
zum teil als angebots dabei haben dann
kommen sie alle
sie kommen aber auch aus einzel
pilgerinnen und pilger und wollen dann
aber auch nicht irgendwie abgespiesen
werden mit mit 23 minuten sondern das
was ich auch ein gespräch entwickeln
können hängt dass leute die schon länger
nicht mehr gebeichtet haben oder
vielleicht zum ersten mal kommen es geht
alles es gibt jene die regelmäßig
beichten gehen und dann nach einsiedeln
kommen und das gefühl haben es tut mir
gut hier
ich hatte auch schon leute die mir
gesagt haben ich bin nach 40 jahren das
ist immer halt wieder in einem fahrstuhl
es gibt auch leute die dann sagen bitte
helfen sie mir ich habe keine ahnung wie
das geht ich war noch nie der beichte
und das kommt häufig vor etwa auch weil
leute kommen die vielleicht gar keine
christliche religionsunterricht haben
gibt es heute auch es gekommen auch so
weich und das bereitet ihnen keine
schwierigkeiten die beichte eine sphinx
abzunehmen eines muslims eines juden
also grundsätzlich kommen die menschen
nicht für die beichte sollten die war
echt ist für die menschen da also wenn
mir jemand entgegenkommt versuche ich
aus dieser situation etwas zu machen
damit dann den konkreten menschen
geholfen
dass ich ihm dann aber nicht eine
bibelstelle vorleser oder ihr nicht die
absolution gebe im namen des
dreifaltigen gottes ist dann für mich
eigentlich schon eine
selbstverständlichkeit denn ich bin ja
nicht darum die leute zu überfahren
sondern sie haben irgendein anliegen und
das muss ernst genommen werden
was machen sie mit menschen die kommen
und sagen ich möchte meine gedanken
meine belastungen hier vielleicht
abladen aber ich bin völlig ungläubig
verstehen ich atheist ich auch ob die
dann immer gehört in den weg in den wald
stattfinden
also es gibt ja warum es noch ganz
andere anlaufstellen die kommen
vielleicht in die kirche
und wo er mit einem mönch sprechen und
sagen dann am anfang also ich bin gar
nicht gläubig aber das interessiert mich
oder die melden sich via internet im
beichtstuhl drin sind dann die leute
eigentlich schon mit irgendeiner
sehnsucht das mit schuld umgegangen wird
es war den religiösen eine einem einer
redaktionskolleginnen hat wird sich
gerade den selbstversuch gemacht und ist
ins kloster gekommen und hat so eine
beichte abgelegt und man kann ihren
erfahrungsbericht online auf unserer
kultur platt platz plattform nachlesen
deine straßberg ist es für sie
nachvollziehbar dass menschen heute mit
einem trotz einer säkularen angebots und
trotz kirchlicher distanz liebe leute
heute zum teil haben trotzdem den weg in
die kirche finden um eine weiche
abzulehnen
was ist das ein grundbedürfnis des
menschen und die beichte abzulegen das
werk ein grundbedürfnis zu sein aber
eine sehr nachvollziehbare reaktion aber
es ist ein grundbedürfnis mit
schuldgefühlen zu einem anderen menschen
zugehen und diesem mitzuteilen
ich bin immer mit diesen
grundbedürfnissen sehr vorsichtig ich
glaube diese vorstellung von beichte
schuldbekenntnis und so weiter ist eine
relativ neue vorstellung
ich glaube das musste man muss einen
historischen zusammenhang sehen zum
beispiel im judentum gibt es die
vorstellung der barig der auch das
sündenbekenntnis es eigentlich nicht es
ist entschuldigung die ausdrucksweise
ist völlig wurscht was sie denken es ist
wichtig was sie tun
aber sie haben doch im judentum auch die
gesetzestreue die verlangt und den
menschen und wenn man ein gesetzesbruch
begeht dann ist das auch ein vergehen
gegenüber gott wickelt dann die jüdische
mensch mit dieser situation um
ja da kommt der begriff der zu war zwar
kann man übersetzen rückkehrer aber kann
man übersetzen mit antwort dass beides
selbe wort und damit um indem er das
nicht mehr tun als kreative wenn er
einen schaden angerichtet hat er den
schaden wieder gut macht punkt das ist
alles das ist also eine sehr weltliche
betrachtungsweise es könnte nicht und
der unterschied zwischen weltlicher und
und um nicht weg sondern um den
unterschied zwischen die innenwelt und
außenwelt die vorstellung ein beichte
ist dann die vorstellung einer innenwelt
gebunden
oder anders gesagt das ist dann die
vorstellung gebunden dass es wichtig ist
was für intentionen in jemand hat und
nicht ganz so wichtig was er wirklich
tot
und diese vorstellung der seele als
innenwelt die seele die intentionen hat
die motivationen hat und dass diese
motivation wichtig sind
die ist eigentlich am anfang der moderne
gebäude gibt es als pflicht seit 1215
vor gab es das nicht und ich glaube dass
die beichte ein ganz wichtiges
instrument war in der kulturgeschichte
zu installation der innenwelt dass man
kann ja sagen zur installation des
gewissens das gab es vorher gab es
damals bevor die leichte eingeführt
wurde schon so etwas wie das was ich
heute ja auch anbieten zusätzlich
seelsorgerische gespräche
ich bin ja nichts sonst werde ich nicht
so schwarz hier das mönchtum beginnt
eigentlich in der ägyptischen wüste und
da kann man schon nachlesen wie frauen
und männer in die wüste rausgehen um
diese mönche und auch nonnen aufzusuchen
und mit ihnen ihr eigenes leben
anzuschauen
wir nennen das heute geistliche
begleitung übrigens ganz interessant wir
haben noch viele aussprüche dieser
ersten wüsten seite und die werden sie
oft so an den anfang von psychotherapie
hergestellt weil das zum teil ist nicht
einfach eine unterscheidung zwischen
weltliche und religiöse sondern die auch
etwas zu sagen haben über das psychische
wohlbefinden eines menschen also das
sind schon die kaum ist sich die
christenverfolgung fertig beginnt
eigentlich dieses hingehen zu mönchen
und nonnen um das eigene leben mit ihnen
anzuschauen
diese tradition kommt als griechen tun
nicht aus dem judentum dieses anschauen
des eigenen lebens das ist eigentlich
etwas was die juden nicht wahnsinnig
interessiert aber es gibt auch thema wie
soll ich legen wie soll ich handeln also
diese exerziert ja zum beispiel marc
aurel schreibt dass man immer am abend
aufschreiben muss was man den tag
durchgemacht hat um sich rechenschaft
über das was man getan hat also
letztlich doch die moralische bewertung
des guten ganzen handels aber nur des
handelns nicht des gefühls also die
schlechten und guten gedanken die
schlechten und guten motivationen die
heute im zentrum stehen die gab es
damals noch nicht
machen wir noch einen schritt weg von
den innenleben gehen wir noch mal zurück
zu den äußeren was ja auch auffällt ist
und sie hatten wir das eigentlich im
vorgespräch auch schon angetönt dass das
beichten etwas ist dass es nur in der
katholischen römisch-katholischen und in
der orthodoxen christenheit gibt obwohl
martin luther nicht beabsichtigt die
leicht abzuschaffen warum ist die
beichte bei den reformierten heute nicht
zuzutrauen
vieles was wir heute als typisch
reformiert und typisch katholisch
anschauen kann man nicht unmittelbar auf
die zeit der reformation zurückführen
sondern auf die zeit danach und man sich
abgegrenzt hat wo man gesagt hat
also weil du im gottesdienst deutsch
spricht werden wir nur noch lateinisch
und zu sagen wir sind dann die und
umgekehrt
das martin luther zum teil noch bis fast
täglich zur beichte ging als es ihm
schlecht ging
das ist heute weniger bekannt nicht
übrigens dass er keine kritik an der
praxis der damaligen zeit gehabt hätte
das war sogar sein haupt gab es eine
seine hauptkritik punktgenau aber er hat
damit nicht die beichte abgeschafft dass
das abschaffen von gewissen tradition
die dann einfach wirklich zum stillstand
kommen hat sehr viel mit der zeit danach
zu tun
ich habe einen für mich verblüffend dass
die tat gefunden von martin luther dass
er angeblich in seinem großen pazifismus
geschrieben haben soll ich zitiere
willst du es aber verachten so stolz
ohne beichte hingehen so fällen wir das
urteil dass du kein christ ist also
keine beichte kein christ r starten sie
das würden sie das unterschreiben
ich muss ein solches zitat natürlich
immer in seinem uhr kontext jetzt müssen
wir die ganze stelle lesen verstehen
denn so könnte ich das jetzt nicht sagen
also auch martin luther könnte ich mir
vorstellen würde heute einem
lutheranischen gläubigen nicht sagen du
bist kein christmas keine christin wenn
du nicht gehst ich glaube hier geht es
ihm wirklich vor dem sein vor gott und
er hat das in der beichte so erfahren
dass man dort in diese freiheit kommt
frei in christus wie es paulus sagen
würde
aber wie gesagt er müsse man ist das
ganze anschauen und bleiben wir mal bei
der frage der schuld wenn wir den ersten
schritt der beichte betrachten so ist
dass die das bekennen das formulieren
dass verbalisieren von schuld und da
werden sie kann ich einfach stehen also
den bekennen voraus geht ja die
reflexion
da geht ja wirklich das
das bewusstsein voraus es gibt ja in ein
grund warum die person kommt das wäre
dann die vorbereitung ja aber auch in
der beichte selber dass man wir beginnen
mit einem religiösen kontext dass wir
machen auch in der katholischen bereich
der wirklich auch das kreuzzeichen
miteinander dass wir da nicht irgendwie
das gefühl haben wir sein irgendwo
sondern das eigentlich ein liturgischer
akt der hier geschieht und dass dann die
person sagt ich bin gekommen und dann
bekennt was sie schon versucht hat für
sich vor der beichte aber doch zu beginn
der beichte zu überlegen es kann nämlich
auch sein dass ihn und sagt ich weiß ich
weiß ich muss hier her kommen aber ich
weiß nicht genau wie ich das sagen oder
warum ich das sagen soll oder was ich
sagen soll
da kann es möglich auch sein dass es zu
einem entwickeln eines gedanken kommt
aber der ausgangspunkt ist ein schuld-
oder schuldgefühle ja davon gehe ich aus
im vorgespräch mit ihnen daniel
strassberg als ich sie nach der schuld
fragt aus psychoanalytischer sicht
sagten sie
schuld sei aus der sicht der
psychoanalyse völlig uninteressant und
ich glaube dort ist auch der große
unterschied zwischen beichte und
psychoanalyse
obwohl das gerade modern ist oder war
eine sechziger jahren das zu vergleichen
vor allem durch michel foucault ich
glaube die schuld interessiert den
priester und interessierten
psychoanalytiker nicht warum hat sich
der psychoanalytiker mit den
schuldgefühlen befasst kann man das
voneinander trennen das muss man
voneinander trennen die h sie müssen
hier vergeben werden wie wenig schuld
mit schuldgefühlen zu tun haben wenn sie
daran denken zum beispiel das
psychopathen ganz viel schuld auf sich
laden überhaupt keine schuldgefühle
haben und sie oder andererseits
depressive menschen die ungeheuer
schuldgefühle haben ja keine ahnung
weshalb irgendwie habt
caracas wenn sie gerade daran denken
dass besonders gute reflektierte
menschen viel schuldgefühle haben
verbrecher keine oder wenn sie daran
denken dass leute mit wahnsinnig viel
schuldgefühlen ein grässlicher auf die
nerven gehen können und fordernd und
unangenehm sein können und überhaupt
kein empfinden für schuld hat sondern
nur für schuldgefühle
ich glaube es gibt aber einen gewissen
widerspruch zwischen schuld und
schuldgefühle
der liegt darin dass das real dass leute
mit vielen schuldgefühlen keine reale
schuld kein reales schuldbewusstsein
haben
kriegel verwirrten jetzt vielleicht
sagen die psychoanalyse versucht den
menschen dar und einzureden sie tragen
keine schuld sei eigentlich es gibt
eigentlich keine schuld es gibt nun das
gefühl dass würden in ihren wagen ich
würde nur sagen wenn jetzt jemand kommt
und ein mord begangen hat und jetzt
schuldgefühle hat und eine psychoanalyse
machen möchte da würde ich hatte nicht
so ein extremfall aber solche ähnliche
fälle habe ich und dann kann ich nur
sagen sie haben zu recht schuld gewesen
da kann ich einfach nichts dazu
beitragen würden sie dann allenfalls
einen patienten an die kirche verweisen
wie das täte jung gemacht hat angesagt
die polizei vorbei ist und sagen also
ich war der polizei stellen sonst mache
ich es nämlich nein ich würde eher sagen
ich hab dir nichts zu sagen
könnten wir noch irgendwo sagen dass sie
ihre patientinnen und patienten zur
medienfreiheit in kontakt bringen
möchten während wir sie haben vorher von
innenleben und moral gesprochen
versuchen dann zu zeigen wie könnte man
mit dieser freiheit umgehen natürlich
von einem christlichen kontext her
sie sind die nehmen sich natürlich auch
wertneutral bei uns ist das ja so bayern
ja sie dürfen ja eigentlich nicht
stellung nehmen werden dich zum beispiel
dann sagen kann
bei uns würde jesus so damit um gewinnen
oder höher hat so ein wort gesagt
irgendwie so etwas
ich würde das etwas spezifizieren wollen
das mit der freiheit das ist nicht
falsch aber man ist ja etwas genauer
sein wenn jemand zu mir kommt mit
schuldgefühlen da gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten das eine er sagt ich weiß
gar nicht weshalb ich die habe oder es
gibt die zweite möglichkeit dass er sagt
ich habe es wegen in irgendeinem
vergehen von dem man das gefühl hat dass
er vollkommen inadäquat dass es
schuldgefühle auslöst oder zumindest in
diesem maße auslässt was ich als
psychoanalytiker tue und das hat sehr
wohl etwas mit freiheit zu tun ist die
schuldgefühle an ihren platz zu tun es
gibt eine sehr sehr schöne stelle bei
frau in seinem berühmten fall dem rat
man der ratten mann hatte ungeheure
schuldgefühle und hat von freud ihnen
verlangt dass er ihn absolviere so zu
sehr hatten und freud hat dann
geantwortet wenn sie schuldgefühle haben
dann haben sie sie zu recht sie wissen
nur noch nicht weshalb
und da kommt das unbewusste ins spiel
also was wir tun ist das schuldgefühl an
den platz zu verweisen wo es herkommt
und dann und da haben sie völlig recht
dann ist eine freiheit im umgang möglich
solange ich nicht weiß woher die
schuldgefühle kommen kann ich nichts
damit machen da habe ich einfach während
das wichtige unterschiede dass er sagen
können wer zu ihnen zur bekommt er
bekennt nur bewusste schuld
viele sagen übrigens auch ich bekenne
auch die die mir nicht bewusst ist
einfach aus dem bewusstsein heraus dass
ich wahrscheinlich immer etwas tue was
andere verletzen oder mich selber
verletzen kann oder dass ich mir dessen
bewusst bin dass das wird sehr oft auch
gesagt aber sie ergründen dann nicht
woher diese dieses verhalten kommt das
zu schuldhaften verhalten wiederum hielt
ich glaube hier sind wieder im sehr
wichtigen punkt wo wir uns unterscheiden
müssen was ich bin ich habe vielleicht
ein paar psychologische kenntnisse
mitbekommen im studium aber ich bin
nicht psychoanalytiker es kann sein dass
ich jemandem sage wissen sie ich kann
ihnen die lossprechung von gott her
geben aber sie müssten wenn sie das
ernsthaft anschauen möchten zu einem
psychologen zu einem psychiater je
nachdem also da muss sich ja auch ein
priester dann ganz klar abgrenzen und
nicht etwas tun wollen was nicht in
unsere kompetenz liegt was ein weiterer
glaube ich sehr zentraler unterschied
ist am ende der beichte steht ein
verzeihen
das vermag psychoanalyse nicht wenn ich
jetzt ganz orthodox wäre also im
orthodoxen nein nein das kommt auf
keinen fall vor ich verzeihe nicht ich
mache nur das unbewusste bewusst aber es
ist natürlich nicht zu bestreiten dass
das ist dieses moment des verzeihens in
der psychoanalyse gibt herr hat seiten
dass ich aus die analytiker sage das ist
nicht so schlimm
oder machen sie sich da kein kopf raus
oder dass diese entlastungsfunktion der
psychoanalyse zwar in diesem orthodoxen
sinne des reinen bewusst machen nicht
vorkommen dürfte aber natürlich unser
alltag ist also das ist was dann wieder
verbinden wer also bei ihnen suchen die
leute in der beichte eine erleichterung
eine heilung vielleicht auch irgendwo
und bei ihnen suchen sie auf heilung sie
gehen ja zu ihnen zu einem arzt muss
vielleicht ein bisschen schwarz weiß zu
sagen sie korrigieren nicht wenn ich das
haus schwarz weiß sage
bei ihnen ist eigentlich das ziel dass
sie wieder zurücktreten denn der mensch
selber weiß jetzt wie zb etwas
orientieren kann während ich bewusst
dann am schluss gott im mittelpunkt
stelle und sage von gott her wird
hierfür ziehen
also ich nehme mich da in dem sie nicht
zurück das war übrigens der konflikt
zwischen freud und jung das hat freut
dann jung vorgeworfen sie sind
pfarrerssohn sie wollen immer den leuten
sagen was sie tun sollen ich bin
analytiker ich analysiere nur das war
ein großer streitpunkt zwischen beiden
hat dass er auf dem pfarrerssohn
zurückgeführt eine gemeinsamkeit die mir
auch auffällt ist bei beiden handelt es
sich um ritualisierte gespräch sie haben
einen festen ablauf und der beichte ich
mir mal jemand kommt haben sie auch
einen festen ablauf aber ein unterschied
ist ihnen muss ich wahrscheinlich
häufiger kommen bei ihnen ist es mit
einem mal erledigt und es ist europa
kommt noch dazu mit eimern erledigt ich
selber gehe nicht nur einmal in meinem
leben also ich versuche unterwegs zu
sein unterwegs auf gott hin
man muss vielleicht historisch
betrachtet sagen das eigentliche wir
nehmen das bei unserer katholischen
tradition nach produkten wie einen das
sakrament das eigentliche sakramente
taufe und das haben die menschen aus
erwachsene erhalten und haben dann
gesagt das ist für mich eine umkehr eine
umkehr zu diesem neuen leben in christus
und dass man gemerkt hat der mensch hat
die besten absichten und vorsätzen und
geht dann doch auch wieder wege wo er
sie am anfang gesagt hat man denn möchte
ich hier nicht mehr gehen
da kommt dann dieses sakrament der
versöhnung hinein dass man sagt ich
möchte mich da öfters auch wieder
versöhnen mit mir mit der kirche und mit
gott
und von dem hier natürlich für das eine
mal wenn du das spürst du kommst raus
und du bist dir ist vergeben dann ist
das ein sehr schönes gefühl das heißt
aber nicht dass du das nachher nicht
wiederholen kannst wir haben sogar bei
ihm situation dass man sagt für die
großen feste also man fest zu feiern
möchte man eigentlich in reinen tisch
haben um dann wirklich feiern zu können
und das sind normalerweise ostern aus
das größte fest des christentums aber
auch pfingsten weihnachten dass man sich
darauf vorbereitet durch die beichte
das ist an vielen orten noch gute
tradition eine weitere unterscheidung
oder 1 1 eine weitere andersartigkeit
die mir bei der analyse in den sinn
kommen zwischen beichte und
psychoanalyse
ich habe den eindruck wenn man zur
beichte kommt dann geht es darum dass
der mensch sich demütig verhält oder
auch demütig wird durch die beichte weil
der psychoanalyse habe ich den eindruck
es geht genau um das gegenteil es geht
um das heben des selbst wertes um
vielleicht auch ein bisschen das meeren
des egos ich glaube das ist ein
missbrauch der psychoanalyse als
religion und treffen
also ich glaube es kommt auch bei mir
von einem gar nicht mehr in den sinn
kommt da macht man heben des
selbstbewusstseins das gibt das wirkt
immer sagen das ist nicht aber das haben
die psychologie ist eigentlich nichts zu
tun denn es geht darum verbindungen her
bewusst zu machen reflexionen zu machen
die einem wie abt urban gesagt hat in
die freiheit führen und dieses dieses
gesülze dass ich immer wieder von der
psychoanalyse höre dieses heben das
selbstbewusstsein halte ich für verfehlt
was fangen sie den mitteln bekämpft der
demut an als psychoanalytiker das ist
einfach ein begriff der in psychoanalyse
nicht folk also das ist ein wesensfremd
begriff das hat etwas so viel zu tun mit
der psychoanalyse weder begriff motor
oder benzin und wenn ich sie als
philosoph frage bin ich wieder philosoph
frage würde ich sagen das und da können
sie mich aber auch als psychoanalytiker
fragen es gibt ein bewusstseinsprozess
in der psychoanalyse der manchmal nach
vernachlässigt werden dass es darum geht
die eigenen abhängigkeiten zu erkennen
was sie vorher angesprochen haben ist
die eigene abhängigkeit nur zu
unterbrechen oder abzuschaffen
und ich glaube es gibt diesen prozess
dass man mit der zeit erkennt dass man
eben nicht unabhängig ist wie man
gemeint hat es gibt ein ganz wichtiges
beispiel aber das kennen die meisten von
uns wenn man älter werden in den spiegel
schaut man ja aus wie sein eigener vater
und dann ging ich weiß wie es bei den
frauen habe ich noch nie gehört damit
meine meinung ist das eindeutig so und
dann erst alle erschrecken und das hat
genau damit zu tun man meint man sei
wahnsinn in bewegung geworden und
unabhängig geworden ein eigenes leben
und am schluss deswegen ist man dasselbe
was vorher mal hergekommen ist und ich
glaube dieses prozess das bewusstsein
der eigenen geht dann könnte man einem
religiösen kontext de mut demut religiös
leider ist ein negativ behaftet weil ich
glaube auch viel unfug getrieben wurde
man hat leute damit gedemütigt aber
demut ist für mich ein positiver begriff
familie aus dem lateinischen hat mit
humus zu tun also jemand steht mit
beiden füßen auf der erde leben auf der
erde und religiös gesagt möchte nicht
selber gott spielen
also man weiß im bereich aber auch
ausserhalb der beichte in der demut dass
man einen auftrag hat eine verantwortung
dass man dem nicht immer entspricht das
man aber auch jetzt nicht abheben muss
um zu sagen ich weiß alles besser und
wenn es nach mir geht ist die welt
gerettet da bin ich eigentlich froh um
demut und ich möchte noch für viele
leute die in dieser welt verantwortung
haben wünschen dass sie mir den mut
haben und wirklich auch in der
verantwortung für die welt für ihre
völker handeln und nicht nur noch
einigen eigenen machtstreben gehen wir
über zu einem anderen thema als
psychotherapeut und auch als beicht
abnehmer befinden sie sich unter
umständen beide in delikaten situationen
insbesondere sie hatten es schon
angesprochen wenn sie konfrontiert
werden oder kenntnis nehmen müssen dass
strafrechtliche delikte geschehen sind
sie sind dann an die arztgeheimnis
gebunden sie sind an ein beichtgeheimnis
gebunden und wir schauen uns jetzt eine
filmszene an die dieses beichtgeheimnis
und auch den gewissenskonflikt den
dieses weist kleines auslösen kann
eindrücklich darstellt er findet sich in
dem film icon fest von alfred hitchcock
aus dem jahre 1953
ich will beichten gott dem allmächtigen
und ihnen priester dass ich gesündigt
haben
wann haben sie das letzte mal gebeichtet
ich kann mich nicht entsinnen können sie
es mir nicht annähernd sagen ich habe
mist getötet
weiter
ich bin eigentlich sein haus gegangen
ich war die bestehe nicht erkennt ich
wollte die polizei ruft urban das
dilemma des priesters ich möchte ihnen
an dieser stelle einige heikle fragen
stellen und ich möchte sie gerne an
einem hypothetischen fall festmachen
angenommen jemand aus ihrer
klösterlichen gemeinschaft kommt zu
ihnen und beichtet ihnen sexuelle
missbrauch an kindern
was sagen sie dann was tun sie was raten
die wie reagieren sie als beichtvater
diesen konstruierten fall kann man sehr
gut vergleichen mit dem was wir jetzt
bei hitchcock gesehen haben der in
siegburg liebe ich nach wie vor aber
genau solche dinge nicht passieren gibt
es im kirchenrecht natürlich auch
bestimmungen was einen mord kann ich
nicht einfach sagen ich kann ich die
jungs mal gehört dass billig nicht
einfach los und sage g weil in einem
kloster ist dafür geschaut dass ein
mönch nicht bei seinem eigenen abweichen
kann
das genau nicht solche
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse entstehen
seien sie positiver oder negativer art
also der könnte gar nicht zu mir kommen
und unter dem bett was sagen wo ich
nachher gar nicht handeln kann sondern
ich bin als obere das weiß er natürlich
verpflichtet solche dinge ernst
anzuschauen auch eine meldung zu geben
und dann die konsequenzen zu ziehen und
dass das eben nicht so einer situation
kommt dafür dass gesorgt sind sie dazu
auch verpflichtet wenn eine
priesterliche person aus einer anderen
verein jetzt nicht zu ihrer
klösterlichen gemeinschaft gehört zu
einer beichte ablegen würde bei mir weil
ich nein da bin ich nicht verpflichtet
weil und nun werden sie in diesem moment
konnte bei der beichte haben sie immer
die möglichkeit zu sagen ich bin hier
nicht kompetent in diehlo sprechen zu
gehen
vor allem nicht wenn sie mir nicht die
möglichkeit geben dass wir das
ausserhalb der beichte anschauen
also da muss man eigentlich jemanden
darauf verpflichten mit dem strafrecht
ich habe mir vorher gehört das ist im
fall des mordes gebracht dass man das
auch strafrechtlich anschaut das geht
nicht einfach das ich so mache und die
leute gerne daraus also habe ich sie
richtig verstanden sie könnten in diesem
moment oder würden in diesem moment die
beichte gar nicht abnehmen und keine
absolution erteilen wenn ja in einem
ersten fall ja lange straßberg es ist ja
auch denkbar und wahrscheinlich haben
sie oder möglicherweise haben sie schon
solche situationen erlebt dass auch zu
ihnen menschen in die sprechstunde
kommen und erkenntnisse abliefern die
strafrechtlicher natur sinn wenn jemand
jetzt auch mit pädosexuellen neigungen
kommt oder gewalt zu gewalt neigt wie
wir müssen sie sich dann verhalten was
tun sie was tun sie als arzt was müssen
sie tun in einem strafrechtlichen sinn
unterschied aber von pädophilen
neigungen oder pädophile handlungen
ich glaube eine ganz wichtige
voraussetzung des psychoanalytikers ist
dass er nichts von patienten will das
heißt dass er nicht in einer irgendetwas
eine richtung dass er auch nicht für
sich wegen dass er aus für die therapie
zu machen nicht wählen und es gibt
situationen da will ich etwas
also ich will dass er das nicht mehr tut
ich glaube ich könnte einen solchen
menschen nicht behandelt ich habe eine
situation gehabt aber ein patient auf
der flucht von keefe das war die einzige
heikle situation in meinem leben hatte
sie ein patient von auf der flucht von
gefängnis zu mir kommen wollte
und den habe ich auch nicht mehr
handelbar sein mandant grund weil ich
gedacht habe nur ein zeugen ist es nicht
zurück muss ins gefängnis
also ich glaube in solchen heiklen
situationen bin ich als therapeut
überhaupt nicht in einer schwierigen
situation weil ich das einfach nicht
kann
suizidalität ist auch so ein problem
dort will ich dass er überlebt das kann
ich auch nicht psychoanalytisch
behandeln was machen sie dann reagiere
ich einfach als psychiater und mache
eine einweisung oder beim medikamente
oder was auch immer dann erforderlich
ist aber ich arbeite nicht als
psychoanalytiker jetzt der fall dass wir
etwas strafrechtlich relevantes
innerhalb einer therapie erzählt oder
den gab es noch nicht und die frage ist
wenn ich jetzt diese therapie verweigere
und den muss ich dann zur polizei gehen
oder so und da gibt es eigentlich
relativ formalisierte verfahren die ich
dann ich kenne keinen auch nicht
auswendig aber die die mich dann von
meinem eigenen gewissen entlastet das
würde ich dann der staat würde ich muss
ich glaube ich dem kantonsarzt anrufen
und den fragen was man da zu tun
da würde ich mich einfach nicht solche
gewissenskonflikte begeben sondern
würden wir das tun was das gesetz
vorschreibt
sie haben stichwort geliefert darum habe
ich vorher so zögerlich geantwortet es
geht ihnen auch gerade darum dass es
leute gibt ich hatte mal einen fall
eines menschen der pädophile neigungen
ins gespräch gebracht hat und das ist ja
nicht dasselbe wie einen tatbestand
ausführen
das heißt mit solchen leuten kannst du
natürlich die beichte fertig führen
du kannst sogar jemanden ermutigen die
kann ich mit dem im leben weitergehen
käme aber das hat sich jetzt auch noch
nie einen tatbestand der strafrechtlich
dann auch verfolgt werden muss das ist
etwas ganz anderes
okay gut verlassen wir mal dieses thema
ein anderes thema das schon angesprochen
hatte ist die tatsache dass ich glaube
allein das christliche verständnis mit
priestern operiert die sozusagen eine
mitra figur sind zwischen den normalen
menschen und gott wir haben in der bei
station die situation dass es eigentlich
aus meiner sicht eine gewisse
dreiecksbeziehung ist auch viele
katholikinnen und katholiken die ich zur
beichte befragt habe haben mir gesagt
eigentlich weiß ich nicht warum ich das
einen einem beichtvater einem priester
erzählen soll ich mache das direkt aus
mitkommt warum braucht es aus ihrem
verständnis heraus diese mit einer figur
für mich gedacht es beides also das was
jetzt schild und das finde ich
eigentlich auch das normale ich bete in
meinem bekommen das gebiet zu bringen in
jedem vaterunser bete ich verzeihe mir
wie auch ich anderen verzeihe oder in
der eucharistiefeier als in der messe
das ja auch seinen platz schon zu beginn
der feier dann die feier selber der
mensch kann immer um verzeihung bitten
das schön finde ich und das befreiende
gerade für heutige menschen die sich
sehr oft selber überfordern so nämlich
ist wenigstens war ist das sakramentale
los sprechen das heißt gott bindet sich
an ein wort das sagt ich verzeihe dir
dass du das hören darfst aus dem mund
eines anderen
ich bin ja dann zwar in dieser
dreiecksbeziehung der mund aber
eigentlich das dann gott sagt es ist so
du musst das nicht hier erkämpfen das
musst du dir nicht erarbeiten das wird
ihr zugesprochen dass wir nicht dann
einfach eine hochform sag ich einmal des
verzeihens und das nennen wir sakrament
wie auch bei den anderen sakramenten
gott in einer gewissen situation des
lebens da steht und sein wort sagt almli
mit
die den koran liest lese ich natürlich
oft in meiner heiligen schrift davon
dass gott alpha scientist und wenn ich
das laut rezitieren so ist das aus
meiner sicht dasselbe wie wenn mir der
priester das sagt wenn ich das höre also
dennoch die frage warum braucht es diese
mittler figur können es nach schließlich
habe ich glaube wir haben noch einen
ganz wichtigen unterschied ist natürlich
analyse der beichte nicht benannt und
der spielt in diesem fall eine sehr
große rolle
die beichte war ursprünglich ein akt ein
vollzug und kein reflexion sagt also die
beichte selber ist sozusagen die beichte
in dem ich es ausspreche ist die beichte
vollzogen und deshalb gibt es die
absolution wenn sie augustin lesen
sozusagen das grundmodell der
konfessionen ist dann ist das schreiben
dieses buches dieser akt der sich gott
hinzugeben
es geht dort gar nicht so und die
reflexion was bin ich für menschen und
dieser akt der reflexion selbst ist die
darbietung zu gott und oder russo 18
konnte so das öffentlich dafür
geradestehen ist schon der verteilung
sagt ist schon der akt der metamorphose
das lesen sie bei bayer gustin es ist
der akt der bereich der der die
metamorphose ist und das ist der
unterschied zur zur psychoanalyse der es
dort geht es primär nicht um den akt der
psychoanalyse sondern um den reflexion
wegen dem bug pracht auch viel länger
weil es nicht um den akt geht
psychoanalyse zu betreiben sondern um
einen reflexionsprozess in gang zu
setzen und für diesen akt der muss
bezeugt werden
das ist bei uns oder er schreibt ein
buch das bei august in der er schreibt
er auch ein buch dieser akt der
metamorphose muss bezeugt werden und
diesen akt um denen es ein bisschen
runterzuholen auf einer theoretischen
zur praktischen ebene kann dann auch der
sein der ganzen konkreten die tränen
fließen lässt
das heißt eine person die bei mir in dem
beispiel kommt ich nehme an wird vorher
schon gesagt haben gott verzeiht mir das
was ich da jetzt hineinbringen aber
durch das sprechen das laute aussprechen
im namen gottes
darf ich dir diese für zeigen zu
sprechen ich sehr oft für die leute dann
einfach das befreiende warum sie dann
vielleicht wieder in den meisten kommen
das ist für mich nachvollziehbar und
dennoch es gibt ja auch die schwierigen
seiten dieses verhältnisses dieses
dreiecks verhältnisses und eines das wir
jetzt gerade sofort in den sinn kommt
dass ich als frage formulieren möchte
war es in der vergangenheit nicht oft so
dass er die furcht vor der reaktion des
priesters oder die angst vor einer
gewissen buß aufgabe oder vielleicht
auch vor dem erpresst werden viel größer
war des gläubigen der zu dem priester
kam als eigentlich die furcht vor gott
und das wäre dann wiederum ein vergehen
auch nach christlichem verständnis
wichtig also ich denke mir mit dass bei
der schuld wenn wir bei dieser frage
sind sie mir etwas vom in diensten des
menschen also ich sage mal nicht mal
probe und die fragen um den glauben als
auch schulz frage es ist heute schon
fast intime aus wenn es um sexualität
jetzt darüber spricht man heute in der
presse aber nicht die schuld
und wenn es um solch intime sache geht
dann ist natürlich auch der missbrauch
groß das gilt für den religionen das
gilt für die psychoanalyse
überall wo du mit dem kontakt kommst
musst du auch als priester als
psychoanalytiker genau wissen wo du
stehst denn eine solche situation darf
nicht missbraucht werden ob sie kann
das heißt aber auch also sie anerkennen
auch die situation dass sie beide in
einem hierarchischen verhältnis stehen
sie zu ihren patienten sie zu den
menschen die zb kommt ja und ich würde
ich weiß nämlich jeder sehen aber ich
würde dem nie sagen wir sind auf
augenhöhe
ich glaube dass es in den 60er jahren
hat man immer davon gesprochen dass das
immer auf augenhöhe ist
ist es aber nicht die leute erwarten ja
auch von mir als priester sie erwarten
von einem philosophen oder
psychoanalytiker dass der sich damit
schon beschäftigt hat und dass er da
vielleicht auch ein wort geben kann oder
mindestens auch sagen kann
ich kann hier nicht helfen also das ist
quasi beides experten sind beide in
diesem expertenstatus und wer zu ihnen
kommt sucht ihre kenntnis ihr wissen
ja es gibt von lala com ein sehr schöner
ausdruck von suzuka ich bin ein subjekt
von dem der andere annimmt ich wisse
etwas
ich habe das ist beschreibt diese
hierarchischen verhältnisse
ich bin sozusagen experte weil der
andere mich in diesem moment nicht durch
ein bestimmtes wissen oder lernen
sondern er installierte in der
psychoanalyse und auch im beispiel ist
das ja sogar vornehmlich inszeniert mit
dem liegen und dem sitzen also es wird
mir etwas verlieren
ich weiß nicht ob sie das er bei ihnen
wäre es sinnvoll gott verlieren oder
auch von den menschen auch in den händen
es wird mir sozusagen unterstellt dieses
expertenteams und mit dem und wenn ich
das zurückweisen und den patienten sagen
meinen nur ich habe auch keine ahnung
von gar nix dann enttäuscht ich ihn nur
glauben müssen es andere die sich muss
diese ziel eine wunderbare geschichte
von cesare pavese ein ein
widerstandskämpfer der sich als priester
verkleidet in einem bergdorf ein des
zweiten weltkrieges und dann eben zum
priester wird durch die neue durch die
leute gehen zu ihm zur biker und er muss
um sich zu verstecken das und er wird
zum priester weil die leute in zu
christen machen so macht nämlich die
leute zum psychoanalytiker die
eigentliche expertin den eigentlichen
experte bleibt schon die person die
kommt denn sie ist ja für ihr leben aber
kennt ihr leben oder ist es am entdecken
verantwortlich von mir erwartet sie
einfach aus einem priester dass ich von
der kirche her von der bibel her vom
christentum her etwas dazu sagen kann
und am schluss dann auch diese worte der
vergebung spreche wenn man jetzt so
allgemein recherchiert muss man
feststellen der ruf der beichte ist
nicht ein sehr guter mann
es wird oft mit dem thema des
missbrauchs
vielleicht auch nicht aber ich denke
beim thema beichte da gehen die
emotionen sehr schnell hoch noch
schneller als bei der psychoanalyse die
anonymität ist etwas das auch gerade
schwierige situationen herbei
wird der fahrer wusste oftmals über das
ganze dorf bescheid konnte die dinge
gegeneinander oder die menschen noch
gegeneinander ausspielen es wurde mit
angst theologen gearbeitet die menschen
wurden auf ihre schwachpunkte hin unter
umständen hin analysiert und das hat
dann auch weiteren weg bereitet
natürlich für weiteren missbrauch an
welchem punkt steht heute die kirche
wenn es um die aufarbeitung und das
selbstverständnis der priesterschaft bei
der weiche geht die kirche gibt es
natürlich in dem sinne nicht weil sie
weltweit mit sehr verschiedenen kulturen
ist also bleiben wären einmal bei uns im
westen also in der schweiz
ich bin in der glücklichen lage dass ich
nach 1965 geboren bin also ich sehe das
glücklich an andere vielleicht nicht das
ist nach dem zweiten vatikanum uns ein
neubeginn gibt auch immer wieder chancen
also sehr vieles was ich höre von
missbrauch der beichte im sinne von
angst machen von ver demütigen
das bekomme ich von älteren leuten mit
das habe ich selbst so nie erlebt und
ich sehe mich natürlich heute aus
priester in der tradition mit der jetzt
papst franziskus ganz stark stark
operiert indem er zum beispiel dass ihre
barmherzigkeit ausruft indem ich
natürlich auch nicht dann den leuten
sage wir müssten das ist buße und das
brauchte sollten dass ihm diese
perspektive auch stelle und ganz stark
spüren
der papst möchte das mit der
gesamtkirche aber jetzt gerade auch bei
uns im schweizerischen kontext dürfen
wir das noch viel stärker betonen es ist
ein angebot der versöhnung ein angebot
der barmherzigkeit gottes werden wir
noch einmal konkret wenn ich mir als
frau vorstellen zu einem priester zu
gehen und unter umständen ein thema sie
haben zum kult gesprochen die an sich
schon intim ist aber vielleicht auch in
erotischen sexuellen bereich intime
dinge mitzuteilen
so bereitet mir das offen gestanden
solange es keine weibliche
priesterschaft in der römisch
katholischen kirche geht werden die
frauen weiterhin dieser situation aus
jetzt sein und wahrscheinlich auch einem
größeren risiko des missbrauchs
wie fangen sie die frauen die eigentlich
das bedürfnis grundsätzlich nach einer
leichteren seelsorgerlichen gespräch
hätten aber dass aus diesen
strukturellen gründen eben nur von
männern geleistet gilt also ohne dass
ich jetzt da irgendwelche statistiken
dabei hätte aus meiner erfahrung habe
ich das gefühl es kommen mehr frauen als
männer
das möchte ich einfach mal so
dahingestellt haben denn dann sehen wir
ja schon bei der projekte situation dass
sehr viele frauen sehr viel intimes von
sich geben seelsorgerlich es gespräch an
sich ist in erster linie nicht an ein
priester gebunden da kann man auch zu
einer frau gehen sei es einem
pastoralassistentin in einem lern frei
sei es zu einer nonne in einem kloster
sie haben also da schon sehr viele
möglichkeiten von frau zu frau zu
sprechen was bleibt das ist richtig dass
sie wenn sie wenn es um die eigentliche
beichte geht dann sitzen sie aus frau
von einem mann
ich traue mir jetzt einfach zu dass ich
von mir aus nicht eine unterscheidung
mache ob ich eine frau oder ein mann von
mir habe sondern mit dem umgehen was die
person mir sagt ob ich so weit komme
dass die frau dann auch das vertrauen in
mich hat das ist noch mal eine andere
frage
ich muss aber sagen dass ich da bis
jetzt keine schlechten erfahrungen
gemacht habe weil ich ein mann bin gut
gekommen schon sehr schnell zum schluss
und eine frage die mich noch
interessiert daniel straßberg heute ist
oft die rede davon dass in
fernsehdiskussionen oder in sogenannten
reality shows leute sehr gerne sehr
offen aber auch teilweise hemmungslos
ihre innersten schuldbekenntnisse oder
auch intimitäten preisgeben wie
beurteilen sie das aus
psychoanalytischer sicht hat das noch
irgendetwas damit zu tun dass diese
leute einen leidensdruck haben bei denen
sie sachen loswerden wollen oder bewegen
wir uns da schon beim nazismus
ich muss
grundsätzlich sagen dass ich mit solchen
zeit diagnosen wie sie das von heute
beherrschen meine grundsätzliche wir
haben also ich also heute wird sätze die
so anfangen leute bei mir ich glaube das
gar nicht
aus verschiedenen gründen glaube ich
dass diese zeit diagnose nicht stimmt
erstens sind alle realistisches
inszeniert hat so viel ich darf hierher
offenbar ja ja die werden dann
instruiert weil sie was sie dann sagen
sollen was sie sagen müssen
das hat mit der realität genau so viel
zu tun im mit im haus also dass der
realität produziert wird das ist eine
illusion die und zweitens gab es ist
natürlich überall freakshows also das
ist ein menschliches grundbedürfnis wenn
irgendwo menschen bedürfnissen
irgendeinem zuzuschauen der ein freak
ist und der das macht dass ich mich ja
nie getrauen würde das zu machen
also das ist etwa auf dem niveau der
dame ohne unterleib im zirkus und hat
mit mit schuldgefühlen und
schuldbekenntnissen eigentlich überhaupt
nichts aber es hat vielleicht eine
schamlosigkeit zu tun
nein das glaube ich nicht immer mit
schamlosigkeit weil man sie gar nichts
von sich preisgibt man es hat soviel
schamlosigkeit wie ein schauspieler auf
der bühne
man weiß über diese menschen überhaupt
nicht nachher sondern es ist eine
inszenierte realität an der man pass als
passiver zuschauer einen gewissen genuss
haben kann weil man sozusagen etwas in
stellvertretung sieht diese menschen
sind sind nicht harmlos wie irgendein
anderer mensch als eine person die
eigentlich sonst nicht fern schaut und
ich da mal reinschauen frage ich mich
sogar aber dass in sie die medien
fachfrau und die nicht bezahlt werden
dafür also in manchen bestehe ich daran
denke das hat aber nichts mit preisgeben
von inneren zu tun sollten mit reagieren
auf welche fragen die eben inszeniert
sind also ich frage mich manchmal ob die
leute nicht bezahlt
wir sind dafür dass könnten uns
überlegen und sicher können uns auch
überlegen was das für unser vieh unserer
gesellschaft bedeutet dass wir
vielleicht dazu ein eigenes uns solches
anzuschauen und wohin unser schamgefühl
und shoot verständnis sich hin
entwickelt hat ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen beiden ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch
ob der urban federer und daniel
strassberg die bilder und nachrichten
von flüchtenden menschen aus afrika und
dem vorderen orient reißen nicht ab
was können und müssen wir tun in dieser
situation flüchtlingen zu helfen ist
christenpflicht das sagte der jesuit
peter balazs er ist nächste woche hier
zu gast wenn man kollegen norbert
bischofberger
[Musik]